this week on brian ross investigates
mystery of the lake who dumped two
bodies in lake mead outside las vegas
right now investigators trying to figure
out whose remain paddle boaters found at
lake mead
was it the work of the mafia this is a
murder case it obviously wasn't suicide
we'll hear from legendary mob lawyer and
former las vegas mayor oscar goodman
sure they never
expected when the body was placed in the
lake that it would be discovered plus
basketball star lorenzen wright was
murdered by a hitman hired by his
ex-wife now shara wright sentenced to 30
years in prison wants to get out early
did you plot and inspire
to kill your
former husband
no spend directly yes sir but lorenzen
wright's mother says no way
[Music]
we've got the latest on the parole board
decision
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
editors of mediaite from the studios of
the law and crime trial network in new
york city's herald square this is brian
ross investigates
good evening thanks for joining us and
welcome to our friends on facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz and rhonda we
begin tonight with the latest in the
case of the murder of the all-star
basketball player berenson wright who
was killed by a hitman hired by his
ex-wife shara wright she was convicted
for her role and sentenced to 30 years
in prison and this week she became
eligible for parole for the first time
rhonda
that's right brian lorenzen wright's
mother was not happy with the plea deal
shara wright made that allowed her to
avoid a life sentence and she left no
doubt about her feelings at this week's
parole board hearing in tennessee
the murder of lorenzen wright was
actually caught on tape in a 911 call he
made that night
9-1-1 where's your emergency
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
11 shots can be heard he never speaks
wright's ex-wife shara pleaded guilty to
arranging the murder and received a
30-year prison sentence which under
tennessee law meant she was eligible for
parole this year did you plot and
conspire
to kill your your former husband
no indirectly yes sir but
i don't have indirectly by the facts of
the offense from what i have and that's
what i'm trying to figure out and i'm
not really litigating this case you're
already convicted but sarah wright made
new and unverified claims about her
former husband lorenzen mr wright my
husband ex-husband lorenzo and he got
involved in the drug ring
and there were some people
that we owed money to great amounts of
well he owed money to great amounts of
money
and during that process
i decided that i couldn't handle that
because it actually led to a lot of
pressure and
a lot of beatings a lot of things i mean
there was
some suicidal attempts on his end and it
was just too much
prosecutors say she wanted her husband
killed so she could collect on his one
million dollar life insurance policy i
took the plea deal because it was just
in my best interest because i knew what
was being said and i was very depressed
about that and i felt like i was
responsible for lorenzo in a lot of ways
shara and lorenzen's son lorenzen wright
junior appeared at the hearing to
support his mother
even with my mom playing a role in my
father's death
i still had to understand who she is in
my life
um
she is
a victim of domestic violence abuse
whether it is
mental physical or emotional
uh it is not excuse her from the
decisions that she's made
and it doesn't take back the time that
we've lost with my father
uh but i do understand as i become older
how much
mental trauma
physical abuse and emotional push can do
to a person
but lorenzo's mother and his great uncle
were there to strongly oppose shara
wright's potential release saying that
she needed to serve the entire 30-year
sentence
i know the kids are sincere what they
say but i also believe that even they
think their mother did something wrong
and there's no doubt about the record
yes she did something wrong
i personally don't think she served
enough time for her
the act that took my nephew out of this
world
was unbelievable
that was just total evil
there's no way to describe it other than
evil
and if you
parole board let her out now
no way she has not had enough time
to sit down contemplate and realize what
she did i know they love their mother
and they want her to come home just
because she's their mother
but if she was the neighbor next door
that plan to kill their dad it wouldn't
went like this
no and that's why i think she didn't do
30. she'll need to do with 30. you could
love to come home at 30.
i just need for her to do what she did
you pay for
she need to do time
i'm i'm doing life
without my child
so i want her to feel like i feel
left out lost and left out my vote today
is to deny your parole due to the
seriousness of the mess because i
believe released from custody at this
time and appreciate the seriousness
of the crime and hear you
again
on
uh in may
of 2027
2027 before julie back there we're
joined now by terry austin our colleague
here at law and crime and terry you
helped to cover this case uh she got 30
years but the man who actually pulled
the trigger at her behest got life
well that's right and i think 30 years
is probably the amount of time she
should be serving she is up for parole
now and it's interesting because
normally in tennessee it would be after
a third of the sentence which would be
about nine years she's getting three
years credit but there's a special law
in tennessee where you have this safety
valve date when the prisons are crowded
and you can get an early parole hearing
and that's what's happening here and we
saw that one parole board did not want
her to get out and so we'll see what
happens with the other there's seven
total members on that board right
they've yet to vote terry a question for
you from roger schwartz rhonda
shira and lorenzen wright's son lorenzen
jr spoke passionately on behalf of his
mother's release this seems to be a real
family tragedy terry
rhonda it's a horrible tragedy
especially since there were seven
children between the two one of them
died at infancy but all of these
children love their mom they don't want
to think that she's involved in this
they believe her when she said she was
just doing the right thing for the
family so i think it's a tragic sense of
any case because here they're gonna not
have their mother or their father and
they were a very close close-knit family
so we'll see what happens at the end of
the day but yes that whole family is
very much in support of their mother
because they want her home just like
lorenzen's mom said they want her home
as lorenzo's mom said she's doing life
without her son and it was her
determination her perseverance actually
led the police to reopen the case after
it gone quite cold a tribute to that
mother
well that's exactly right and it's a
good thing they kept doing it because
the case went cold for so many years but
this was a brutal brutal murder and so i
believe that she definitely had the
motive and the incentive to make sure
that they found out who killed her son
well it was a tragedy all around terry
austin thank you so much for being here
tonight
thank you all right up next the mystery
of the lake who dumped the bullet-ridden
bodies found in lake mead outside las
vegas was it the mafia long-time mob
lawyer oscar goodman will be here to
give us his insights
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
you